and chris flexon has really pitched well
this year for the mariners going to be
his 31st start on the year looking for
his 15th win a 3-6-7 era for flexson 174
in the third 124 strikeouts and yes he's
in the strike zone just 39 walks on the
year this is where some of your greatest
dreams come to life a must-win game to
stay alive for a playoff birth
3-2 pitch
ground ball tour with the rain slide
throw
just got a nice play
so he said i don't want that happening
to this guy
as he sends one deep to left on the
track right there making the catch dylan
moore two down big out two out nobody on
big flex with a 2-2 pitch
ground ball right to tour
room service
one two three in the first
let's get that offense cranking flex off
to a good start america's coming to back
on the mound for the angels another
left-hander lefties throughout the
weekend and that's a part of seattle's
problem this year but jonathan diaz gets
the ball tonight 25 year old rookie
making his second ever major league
start
really took something off of that one
diaz struck out four marin is on
saturday that's his first tonight france
and henniger aboard with two away
like he cut off his swing there sends a
little lazy fly ball out to rojas to
retire the side two left stranded for
jonathan diaz homered against flexon
back on the 16th of july at angel
stadium it's the 3-2 first of all the
walsh
and that's lined into the gap in right
center field
haniger goes to retrieve it walsh is on
his way to second
with a leadoff double
and he fell one for three last night
right to see
easy play
out of the inning
two-stranded when we come back you'll
get in hebtura leading off for the
mariners
two walks and a single
that was close to a bach move
murphy puts that in play
mayfield bare hands and gets him
like jack mayfield coming in on that
when you think okay with the catcher
running maybe you don't have to go with
the bare hand but he needed to use the
bare hand and all in one motion
here's dylan moore
and the first pitch to him is sent out
to mayfield as well nothing comes to the
one-out walk and we played two complete
in seattle
put him away here two and two
and he does
he'll strike out of the evening one down
here in the third
big japanese presence media presence
here
popped it up
good news j.p
kellnet coming on strong it'll be jp one
two three in the third top of the order
coming up mr crawford will lead off in a
scoreless ball game
they had first and second one out
did not score 1-1
there you go right now field
can't hold on as rojas ty is going to go
for two digging hard he'll get there
crowd is ready to rock
hanny
luke base hit the center outfield deep
for him and field pulled around three to
the left side
the other way big hit here comes time
manny waving him on lojas will get to it
no throw to the plate bears have a
one-nothing lead
mitch haniger with the rbi is 96 then
here come the murders
so far so good for the astros who have
an 8-3 lead
infield pop for fletch
[Applause]
and that retires to side
[Music]
a run on three hits for seattle
one-nothing mariners
there's still gasoline
bunting of beauty flexing off the mounds
sidearm
just got him nice stop ty france holding
the bag one out
[Applause]
nice inning
very nice inning by chris flexing jp's
under it
put it in the book one two three in the
fourth bottom third of the order coming
up to see if jared kelman can
get some offense going here for the
americans to lead one nothing
thank everybody it was very nice yeah
all the pictures from when he started
all the different people he worked with
the bobby mercer all the different
yankees
over the years it was really a touching
moment
moore sends out into right good catch by
jose rojas
boy he's really had a couple of tough
chances tonight jose converts
and it's a one two three fourth for
jonathan diaz
chris flexon has put together a really
solid body of work this year 1-1
and rojas sends a drive out to right
field that ball's got a chance and that
one's going to go
a game-tying solo homer for jose rojas
just like that
that one swing the bat does tie it up
that's a change-up
that rojas hits out his sixth home run
to go along with 14 doubles france
holding the runner on it first one out
double here's what we're looking for
there's one and rackham
tie ball game and 1-1
field straight up for ty here comes a
2-2 pitch
hit hard to the gap
got a chance and well get down
ty france
again showing
outstanding plate coverage drives one to
the right center field gap
one out
go ahead and run at second for mitch
henniger
swinging and drive
deep left center fifth get it up good
[ __ ] come together and the meredith had
to
lead mitch henniger with his 39th home
run
2-1
ohtani runs that swing on popped up long
run haniger long run ty france
nicely done
stayed with it
and it's right up against that screen
that's over there
need the bullpen to pitch out of trouble
two on one out six thinning mariners up
3-1 on a
must-win night but
let's enjoy this
2-2 pitch
strike three crawl got him
needed out two out two on one two pitch
ground ball toro
throw over to first out of the inning
casey sadler
comes to the rescue strands two and the
meredith have a 3-1
lead 2-2
breaking ball slow roller fair ball
sager on the run digging
got him
great play both ends
this is so difficult
kyle playing back looks like this ball
is going to hit the bag at third base
and kyle has to get there before he has
a chance to and get to work his way
around it with his footwork and then get
rid of it quickly at one hot
strike to type france this has turned
into the highest leverage situation of
the game middle of the order
two runners on
and walsh has just hit a three run homer
oh my
wow
walsh did you see the did you see the
drop did you see the bat drop yes
number 28 for walsh
and might just be the blow that ends the
seattle mariners season mariners
fighting for their lives here for
playoff life
biggest pitch of the year here for the
mariners three and two bases loaded
seashell the pitch
base head left down here comes jp
bower scores jp scores
[Applause]
they built statues of players
based on games like this
mitch haniger oh
baby
two and two to six two out two on
there get out get down get down it goes
digging for thorn
bounces around seeker all the way to
second
sound that fog horn
that's some kind of ball game
right are going to take over this right
here is what matters marsh yep and
ohtani on deck which is even scarier
right now
[Applause]
162 and attempts to get into the
playoffs
you